(jazzy music)
- Hi I'm Hannah, you're
friendly neighborhood wine mom
and if you're anything like me,
you believe that a glass of wine at 8pm
makes you a better mom.
So pour yourself a glass and let's talk.
Now today we're drinking a dessert wine.
It is mango wine because I just ate
basically 8,000 grams of
carbs in the form of pizza
and bread sticks and
it's time for dessert.
So a couple of weeks ago we did a video
about judgey parents and
you guys totally owned it
with these amazing comments.
Sharing stories of all the
times that you were judged
and overcame it.
When that video was
released, I was on a trip
with my husband with no service
and I went to this middle
of nowhere rest stop
just to check on the video
and I saw all of the comments
and just burst into tears
in front of everyone
because it was so beautiful.
So thank you so much and
I want to keep it going,
so let's talk about something
that I see in the comments a lot.
It's an issue that we all
have to deal with every day
and it's: How I Learned
To Love My Mom Bod.
Really excited to talk about this.
So first, let's talk about the girls,
'cause when you're pregnant,
your boobs get huge
and they're just like up here
like big perky headlights like,
"Hello baby on the way."
and then as soon as the baby comes out
they just kind of deflate
like sad birthday balloons.
You know when you like,
your kid insists on keeping
them in their room for
like a month and a half
and they're just like barely floating.
But the way I think about it now is,
I kept two humans alive with these.
Literally these things
kept two humans alive.
They have accomplished so much.
So you know what, I'm
gonna let 'em retire.
They did their job.
I'm gonna give 'em a
break for a little bit.
So this ones for you.
I appreciate you.
Next, tiger claws.
Instead of getting like the
typical tiger claw stretch marks
around my belly I got this
weird solo stretch mark right
above my belly button that
like stretched out into a V.
And it's like, I'll show you.
Come.
Come closer don't be shy.
It's like kinda weird.
And I was so embarrassed by it
that for the longest time
after I had my first,
I would not even wear a bathing suit
like a two-piece bathing suit.
I realized that, first of all
I'm not going to the beach
for like some model photo shoot,
so who gives a crap if
I have the perfect body.
Second, I'm not there for
anyone else's viewing pleasure,
like we're all there to
just go to the beach.
And three that mark
is the only reminder I have on my body
of the fact that I had both
of my children in there.
It's mind boggling to look at them now
and see how huge they are
and look down at my little stretch mark
and remember that this
is where they came from.
It's our badge of honor.
It's beautiful.
Next, the pooch.
When your stomach has been
stretched out to about here,
there's gonna be some extra skin.
Every mom's stomach is
not going to be the same
as it was before they had children,
that's just a fact.
Yeah my stomach is a lot
softer than it used to be,
but let's be honest I never
had a six pack to begin with.
And as soon as you have the baby,
there's all this pressure from the media
and peers and strangers
to lose the baby weight.
I don't know why that's even
a priority to other people
who have not even had this baby.
New moms are the most
exhausted people on the planet,
so for them to try to focus
on like exerting more energy
to try to lose weight is ridiculous.
So let's give them a break.
New moms don't have to focus
on losing the baby weight,
just worry about keeping the child alive
and yourself alive.
How 'bout that?
So keep your baby weight, who cares?
Seriously, you look good.
Cheers.
Next, the hoohah because
I'm five years old
and I don't like talking about privates.
Still it baffles me that I am
still asked by so many people,
do the parts go back together
the way that they were?
Duh!
Back in the olden, olden, olden days
children did not survive very well,
so women were supposed
to have multiple kids.
That means this thing,
closes right back up.
Maybe not our tummies, but
down there does just fine.
And I checked with a man.
Ask my husband.
Don't ask my husband, that's weird.
So there's a comment that I
get all the time in person
and in the comments of these
videos and it's always,
"You look amazing for
having had two kids."
and for the longest time
there was this ugly voice
in the back of my head that would say,
"Oh, you're only looking
good for having two kids.
"You don't look good for a normal person."
Something that was meant
to be a compliment,
would make me feel badly about myself.
I felt like my only body identity was mom.
I realized, I of course my
body identity should be a mom
because I birthed two
children and that's amazing.
And to any of you guys who
feel like you have all this
pressure on you to look
perfect or look a certain way
or feeling bad about anything
that is happened to you
as a result of having your child,
you gotta stop.
What you've done is the most
incredible accomplishment
that I could ever think of.
Like literally building a human.
Like you made a brain.
Just in the fact that
there was a brain in there
that you made that's crazy.
And honestly if you're feeling
badly, turn off the TV.
Turn off the computer.
Turn off this crappy media
that's making us feel
like we're supposed to look a certain way
or we're supposed be a certain way.
That's completely
unrealistic and unattainable.
Life is way too short
to spend another second
hating your body.
And I am so freaking
passionate about this,
I'm about to start crying,
I'm not even joking.
I love my mom bod.
I love your mom bod.
You should love your mom bod,
so let's celebrate them.
Let's show them off to the world
because fuck what everyone,
I shouldn't say the f-word,
but fuck what anyone else thinks!
Seriously, fuck that!
We're beautiful and we should
celebrate with lots of wine.
And bathing suits.
So that's all I got for today.
I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood wine mom.
And I know I got a little
bit passionate there,
but this is just something
that I care so much about.
I just wanna like reach through
the screen and hug you all.
One of those long awkward hugs
that you're like patting
me on the back being like,
"Okay, okay."
So I wanna hear in the comments about
why you love your mom bod
and what you love about your mom bod
because they're beautiful
and it's time we take over the dad bods
'cause it's all about the mom
bod because we're awesome.
And we rock and you're all
beautiful and I love you.
So cheers.
'Til next time.
(jazzy music)
Oh sweet barrel wine.
Sweet barrel wine!